exzellenz geht dann vor den vereinten
nationen aufgetreten vor der
un-vollversammlung mensch das war ein
emotionaler auftritt dort auch mit
emotionalen reaktionen
gegen die ukraine wurde ein verbrechen
begangen und wir fordern eine gerechte
strafe
das verbrechen wurde an unseren
staatsgrenzen begangen am leben unseres
volkes gegen die würde unserer frauen
und männer gegen die werte die sie und
mich zu einer gemeinschaft der vereinten
nationen machen
management vor den kram wir fordern eine
strafe das verbrechen der aggression
bestrafung für die verletzung von
grenzen und territorialer integrität
bestrafung die verhängt werden muss bis
die international anerkannte grenze
wiederhergestellt ist bis die aggression
aufhört und bis die schäden und verluste
für den krieg vollständig entschädigt
worden
und nach diesen worten gab es dann
standing ovations in der
un-vollversammlung
stehende ovationen die vertreter
russlands nicht aufgestanden das kann
man sich vorstellen aber ansonsten fast
der ganze saal dort bei den vereinten
nationen das us korrespondent herbert
bauernebel ist tatsächlich nicht alltag
in der un-vollversammlung oder
jetzt tatsächlich ein grosser moment in
der uno in der geschichte der höhepunkt
natürlich bei dieser woche hier am new
yorker east river eine lange rede 30
minuten lang in englisch vorgetragen von
woody allens geht wo er russland
angeprangert hat praktisch die welt
aufgerufen hat russland zur rechenschaft
zu ziehen für die verbrechen die
begangen wurden an seinem land der rief
er in den saal über die videobotschaft
dass die ukraine frieden will das thema
sei dass europa frieden will und dass
eben es wladimir putin ist der hier ein
aggressor ist und das land eine blutspur
durch dieses land zieht besonders
dramatisch war der moment als selensky
pablo ramirez selensky beschrieben hat
ein opfer in eines dieser furchtbaren
massengräber
einem mann der offensichtlich vor seinem
tod kastriert worden ist das ist
natürlich ein schaden durch den saal
gehen es waren deshalb gut besucht
eigentlich für eine abendliche redezeit
man muss sagen mehr menschen im saal als
bei der rede von ab um das kanzleramt
und wohl oder mirza lenski ist nichts
schuldig geblieben er hat wirklich hier
eine dramatische eine historische eine
bewegende rede gehalten und am ende
natürlich verdienterweise eine minute
lang standing ovations wir uns noch ganz
kurz aus new york herbert bauernebel
zittern dort in den usa nach dieser
ansage von putin dieser botschaft via
staatsfernsehen oder eher gelassenheit
das hat die amerikaner ein wenig
aufgeschreckt aber insgesamt bleibt es
bei einer gelassenheit da es ist
eigentlich so dass die meisten experten
sagen aber auch die meisten
militärberater sagen dass wladimir putin
zwar in die enge getrieben ist und
kaltblütig und böse ist aber nicht
verrückt und es wird erwartet dass es
natürlich bei einem nuklearen
provokation von leuten punkte in einen
massiven gegenschlag geben wird welche
details
bekannt werden in den nächsten tagen
wird man sehen aber klar ist die
amerikaner dürften in einem solchen fall
wahrscheinlich einsteigen in der ukraine
gerät so jedenfalls der tenor der
experten und daneben stehende ovationen
für vlotho messe lenski vor der
un-vollversammlung danke an unseren us
korrespondentin herbert bauernebel nach
new york
[Musik]